let me just tell you how cool this
laptop is that 3D laptop everybody's
talking about CEs is here and you're not
going to see 3D on this you can't really
see it because it tracks your eyes this
thing is legit it's like James Cameron
approved I mean I'm joking now in terms
of the specs inside this you got a 13
gen Intel I9 processor you got a 4070
and Nvidia graphics card inside of this
eight terabytes of storage up to 64
gigabytes of RAM and of course this is a
16 inch OLED display it is gorgeous it
is beautiful you can also turn off the
380 if you want to and it's just a beast
and it's coming out in Q3 and I wish I
could show you guys what it looks like
because it's freaking awesome but I
can't you just have to trust me on it
but I think it's got James Cameron
approval you should